[Music]
hello friends welcome once again to our
program i'd like to know
this is one of our favorite programs
because we can have more interaction
with you we can know what is in your
mind as you send us your questions
and today i have the privilege to be
here with my dear pastor pastor c.a
murray associate speaker for secrets and
seal
welcome sir it's good to have you here
good to be here with you daniel and also
thank you for
being here with us we receive a lot of
feedback and a lot of questions we have
an impressive amount of list of
questions as you can tell
and we will do our best to answer these
questions in the order that we receive
them unless we see that a question needs
immediate response
before we begin i would like to remind
you also that you can continue to
participate in sending your questions to
the following email address tv at some
tv.org
again tv at s-u-m-t-v
dot o-r-g
send us your questions and we will do
our best to answer them
before we begin then i would like to ask
pastor c murray to please lead us in
prayer you're glad to do so father god
again we thank you for the privilege we
have of studying your word
we thank you for the power in your word
for the direction that it gives us
as we
walk this road that leads to glory we
thank you for those who have questions
and who are concerned enough about
understanding the word of god to send
their questions in and so father we ask
that our studies might prove fruitful
but more than that that you may speak to
us as you speak through us as we seek to
answer these questions and
give light and give uh an answer where
an answer can be found we praise you and
we thank you in advance for what you
have promised to do and answer to the
prayer of faith in jesus name amen amen
amen
okay so we have um a question that comes
from
sydessa or cybessa from algeria
we sent you greetings brother
and this is a
a very complex question i would say
because uh
we were talking before this program that
we could recall record a whole program
just on this yes we'll see how we'll see
how far we can go
um the question says
he was in sabbath school and he heard
someone say that we are not born sinful
despite our nature being sinful sinful
jesus was born into a sinful nature
but he never sinned
if we are not born sinful then
what did christ really redeem us from by
his death
that's his question
the sinful nature or what
please help me
i don't understand because i used to
think that we are all born sinners
then
when we are born again
we get better and that it's the natural
sin at birth that christ died for
so basically his question is what did
they what did christ die for
what did he redeem us from
and if we are born sinners or not okay
there's there's a lot there yes and
perhaps we ought to un-package it
my pastor my friend
systematically yes uh and it's gonna
take a little while
the first question
dealing with what he
he is asking here
we are not born sinful despite our
sinful nature my my first question
before he went to the bible would be to
ask him
if we're not born sinful despite our
sinful nature when did we pick up our
sinful nature
at what point in our growth process did
we pick it up uh if we weren't born that
way
secondly um there's a difference between
sin and age of accountability right and
that's what he might be thinking of that
that there are there are sins and i'm
trying to unpackage this like an onion
and not go too deep and have to come
back but at a there's a point in time
uh when you you are responsible for your
sins when you know what sin is and at
that point in life you become
responsible for your sins but did you
sin prior to that
i think so
but uh because of your knowledge your
ability your your cognitive ability they
were not held against you now there's a
whole other realm of things that we can
talk about and perhaps we should talk
about that um
sinful propensities right and
sinful infirmities and these come into
play when you're talking about the life
of christ
we have propensities
and infirmities in other words you and i
have been born
6 000 plus years into this thing we look
it and sometimes we feel it you know
yesterday both of us we were we taped a
lot of programs yesterday and we were
kind of dragging around
both of us interestingly enough are sort
of dragging around
because we have the infirmities
you know we don't live as long we don't
some days you don't you know some days
you get up you feel like you can take on
the world
other days you you get up and you feel
like you're carrying the world you know
it's just because of
where we are in the stream of time and
how the human race has declined uh over
the years so we have these infirmities
then there are the propensities well
christ had the infirmities he he came
into this
earth about 4 000 years in and he he
didn't come in as superman he came in as
a man
um with the the infirmities of of of men
he did not have the propensities we come
in with a a bent towards sin yes
christ came with a perfected
relationship with his father but here's
the question let someone think that that
um christ had an advantage my question
is is it harder to get clean or to stay
clean
you know you you you you
we are called to get clean yeah christ
came clean but his call was to stay
clean
and in a sinful world staying clean is
just as hard as getting clean you know
it is you wash your car and you go
outside and uh if it if it's sunny or
rain uh pretty soon your car is dirty
again you know it's hard to keep it
clean well christ had the job of keeping
it clean and he was successful in that
now there's a lot more i could say but i
think you actually do get to talk
so i need to let you speak a little bit
and then i got some more stuff here well
i think you laid a very very important
foundation in this discussion
i think it all boils down into what is
sin
uh according to the bible you got all
this controversy about the nature of
christ and
and victory over sin and
the work of salvation can be clarified
if we have um
clear in our minds
what
sin is
now
the bible says in
first john chapter 3 verse 4 this is a
well-known text that sin the bible says
there that sin
is the transgression
of the law yes the sin is the
transgression of the law
therefore
we understand that same
if it is the transgression of the law
sin
is a choice yes actually ellen white
says that the only definition
let me read it here from from the spirit
of prophecy
this is a
manuscript
153 but this is also found in selected
messages i believe volume one
she says after she quotes first john 3
1-4 she says this is the only definition
of sin in the scriptures
the transgression
of
the law
so she defines that as the only
definition so some people say what about
james 4 17
where it says that if he that knows
what to do the good that he needs to do
when he doesn't do it it is sin it is
sin uh but that's that goes to the same
thing the only the difference is that
there you have sin by omission yes the
person knows what he's supposed to do
but he doesn't do it in that way he's
also transgressing the law of god okay
but anyways so sin is a transgression of
the law now you said someone before the
age of accountability
is transgressing the law
yeah
i mean some babies and some kids are are
selfish by nature and and they are
rebellious
but
they are not conscious about it yes
and there is a difference between having
a simple
fallen nature
and being a sinner and i often ask yes
do we sin
or are we sinners
because we
sin
or do we think because we're saying
exactly
[Laughter]
and that is that is a
a tricky question that can be can be
difficult but very true the bible tells
us that
we are
in psalm 51
that
in sin did my mother conceive me
so the mother was the one that
considered me sin i inherit a sinful
nature
from my parents
but i become a sinner only when i
consciously participate or partake
of that sinful
nature now that is the key and i want to
just pause there because you
i knew you were going to get there
because i know you're kind of a
systematic thorough guy so
because i wrote here sin sins sinner and
sinning okay and so i knew you're coming
and and now that you've gotten there i
think we ought to pause okay because
it's a it's an important point that it
just raised it it is an important point
that
um
uh we we are
sinners by nature if we say we have no
sin
we
deceive ourselves we are lying to
ourselves uh and we make christ alive
because we are sinners we were born in
sin
but there is the the the consciousness
of of of sinning against the lord i mean
when a when a baby is hungry at three
o'clock in the morning he doesn't care
if you're sleeping he doesn't care if
you're
uh tired if you've had a long day he
wants what he wants and he wants it now
sometimes he's crying just because he
wants to see your face you're not hungry
not
he hasn't sold his diapers he just wants
to sort of pull your chain so he cries
until you show up and then he stops he's
fine you know well that's part of that
of that nature um he's not responsible
because he's not doing it uh cognitively
he's just doing it um but it shows the
sinful nature which which comes in with
us and then we of course are called to
overcome uh
that that nature that those inherited
inherited tendencies to send so your
point is very well taken i just wanted
to sort of pause it because you you hit
the nail on the head there
yes oh thank you pastor so
when jesus we should not be concerned if
we have the right definition of sin then
it wouldn't be conflicting to us to say
that jesus took a falling human nature
because having a falling human nature in
itself
doesn't doesn't make you a sinner until
or unless you participate yes of that
following human nature jesus never
participated jesus never had
propensities or inclinations to evil
that he had cultivated
because he never
ever yielded in one particular point to
any temptation that's why he didn't
develop those kind of sinful
propensities you know in the new
testament there are at least two words
there are more
that are used
when it comes to sin one is the word
anomia
and the other word is hamartia amatia
missing the mark
missing the
the most the correct translation
lawlessness
is lawlessness
and hamartium is in the mark now when we
come to the verse first john 3 4
it says sin
hamartia
is anomia that's what it says in the
greek precisely yeah so
um
we see that even
hamartia
is defined as anomia again goes to the
transgression yes of
the law yes yes so
we are not born
um
sinners
when it comes to the definition of
first john 3 4
but we are born with a sinful human
nature yes we're born with sinful
propensities infirmities as you said and
jesus came to redeem us
from
sin now we will have the falling human
nature until jesus comes
okay
and when jesus comes we will be
transformed
into a glorious body yes but
uh we
we are not
expected to be sinning until jesus come
until jesus comes because as jesus
overcame sin in the flesh we can also
overcome sin in the flesh
through the power of of jesus christ
yeah if we are left to our sinful nature
we are of all men most miserable yes you
know the good thing about first john 1 9
is that he forgives us of our sin
then and then he cleanses us from our
hands you know if he just if you just
forgive forgive forgive forgive and
never cleanse and we become perpetual
sinners we're getting forgiveness but we
never get victory
and and christ died to give us among
other things victory
and it makes god kind of a toothless
tiger indeed
uh you when when you and kelly are
blessed to have children
if you just tell them don't
and
they
affront you they do it and you just say
don't
and they do it again and you just say
don't after a while they realize you are
a toothless tiger you know your words
are just words there's nothing behind
your words you're just talking so you
actually encourage them in sin because
you don't do anything about it well
you've either got to punish or to
cleanse or to do both
god chooses to forgive and to cleanse so
that you are not
you are not forced to keep on sinning
you get cleansing but you also get
strength to say notice and that's part
of the process ellen white says this sin
is an an intrusion into the universe for
which no reason can be given you know i
can't say well the dog ate my homework
the devil made me do it you know it just
doesn't it doesn't work that way
there's no reason for it but it does
exist yes but praise god we are not left
to it we can become victorious over it
and christ gives us gives us the power
to do that amen
amen so it's it's a really good question
and it's a question that has been asked
through the years down through the ages
because people want to know the nature
of god the nature of man uh how do we
deal with sin how does sin affect us i
am so glad romans 8 1 there is now
therefore no condemnation to those who
are in christ jesus it's a powerful text
and it be speaks god's power in us to
overcome sin and sinning
you know in closing with this question i
would recommend my brother si vessel
that
you go to our
youtube channel to our website and you
will find
a symposium that our ministry did in
last generation theology symposium in
that symposium there are some
presentations
when in regards to the to the subject of
sin what sin is
so go there and also there are some town
halls panel discussions and people with
different
uh opinions and
and input they discuss the subject of
sin and some of those questions and you
will be greatly blessed
all right
this was a good question you know i it
it tends to come up periodically and
that shows the importance of this
question uh because people want to know
uh and there are
um individuals who have uh perhaps um
not a full full understanding of the
question so it's going to come again and
and of course we are
ready to answer it as many times as that
comes because it is a an important
question
and a question that is vital to your
understanding of the power of god to
overcome sin in your life amen through
the indwelling of the holy spirit so we
are we're happy for for that question
amen all right
so we have another question from matthew
c d
and this question
has to do with
physical or literal israel and the third
temple he says
is there any light either in the bible
or the spirit of prophecy
about the physical israel
do you expect the third temple to be
built
as the christian church
as the christian churches teach
thank you
you know lately this topic has been
agitated
especially now with russia again coming
into power in the political scenario
which is very linked to the rebuilding
of the third temple
i've heard
recently that even the measures are
being
taken to rebuild the third temple
in there in jerusalem
and many christians are
fixing their eyes in jerusalem
for the future rebuilding of the third
temple does the bible teach that
you know there are some depending on how
you look at the temples the first temple
the second temple the third temple there
there's so much controversy on this
issue that some people say the third
temple has already been built that's
because they they they look at herod's
temple which was really of a
reconstruction correct uh as the third
temple
um i've had the privilege of being in
israel at least seven times uh
and you know to this day i've been all
over israel i've never been
uh
up with the al-aqsa moxes i've never
been up on the temple mount i've been to
the the wailing wall the western wall
but you
are so restricted in your travels you
you really have to set a time and you've
got to get permission it's like
traveling to a foreign country
to to get up there uh because of the
moth that is there
it is my opinion well i've got i've got
several
um
the
idea of a third temple
is not spoken of in the in the word yeah
i don't see it
two it is not necessary to anything
that's going to happen in the in the
eschatological process as we see it
and
um
this increased focus on
jerusalem
as as an integral part of the end time
scenario is not warranted and is not
biblical right uh the next time we deal
with jerusalem is new jerusalem amen but
this jerusalem doesn't have any focus or
real fulcrum
as far as the end time scenarios come if
you're looking at jerusalem you're
looking at the wrong city yes because um
it it i don't see where the bible says
it plays a central part in in the
closing scenes of earth's history uh to
the extent that many evangelicals want
to to place it yes i really like what
you said about fixing our eyes on the
new jerusalem this that's where we were
we were supposed to be fixing our eyes
you know some christians missed
what the bible teaches about the literal
difference between the literal and the
spiritual
in the old testament we have a literal
temple in a literal location
now in the new testament
now the temple
i would say
adopts a spiritual connotation
and
it is no longer referring to
a literal temple here on earth
why
there is a simple reason
when we when we study about the temple
or the century
what makes the century important it's
not the building
it's the presence of god in the building
yes in the shekinah so that's what makes
the temple something important
now the jews
of old
made the great mistake of
looking at the temple as their savior
yes even before the babylonian captivity
and jeremiah rebuked them and said don't
say the temple the temple the temple
because the temple itself is nothing
if the presence of god is not there
so
jesus when he came
hey had prophesied about his coming to
this temple yes which is herod's temple
or the second temple remodel okay
zerubbabel's temple remodeled by herod
but it's the same second temple if or if
you want to count it the third temple it
doesn't matter but it's it's hey get
prophesied about it that's true
and he said that this temple was going
to be greater than solomon's temple why
because the desire of all nations
was going to be their person
now jesus was the desire of all nations
the desire of ages and he stepped into
this temple
but the true presence of god the true
shekinah came and the people did not
recognize him they rejected him and
jesus the la the last time he was in the
temple he said these words in matthew 23
verse
matthew 23 verse 38 this is what jesus
said
see your house is left to you desolate
for i say unto you
you shall see me no more till you till
you say blessed is he who comes in the
name of the lord so
the temple lost its significance yes
when jesus departed from the temple
then now our eyes are supposed to
be where jesus is yes and jesus is now
in the heavenly sanctuary but there is a
spiritual temple here that paul referred
to in several passages for for the sake
of time i will i won't read them all but
first corinthians 3 16
often times we apply this to the body
but in the context is referring to the
church yes when paul says no you know
that you are the temple of the temple
okay it's referring to the church now in
ephesians 2 19 and 22 paul refers to the
believers as
stones
spiritual stones building at the
spiritual temple and the same thing and
and this is this one i i will read in
first peter chapter two verse five
uh first peter
chapter two and verse 5 this is what the
apostle peter says
he also as living stones are are being
built up a spiritual house a holy
priesthood to offer up spiritual
sacrifices acceptable to god through
jesus christ notice that word that
repetition spiritual house
spiritual sacrifices yes so
in the new testament the temple is seen
more as a spiritual temple made up of
the believers yes so when it comes when
he talks about
the
the temple in the new testament
and particularly in second thessalonians
chapter two that's where uh some people
base their prophecies about the
rebuilding of a new temple because there
is a man the man of sin that will sit in
the temple of god yes
that temple is the church the believers
the christian church it is not correct a
literal temple that will be rebuilt in
jerusalem right and a nasty man is going
to go three years and a half later
and he is going to erect an image
and defile the temple yes
yes
a number of things um in john chapter 4
around 21 through 24 when crisis is
going through the dialogue with woman at
the well of course she she is trying to
throw a little smoke in there because
she's trying to get him off of uh he's
he's sort of diagnosing her life and
she's trying to dissuade him
and so she she she floats an old
controversy you know where should we
we we
worship in jerusalem or in samaria you
know uh the samaritan temple had been
destroyed by john heyer canister and it
was still in ruins uh he said but we we
we like like worship here and uh you
guys worship in jerusalem and christ
said uh there's coming a time and now is
that's not going to be important
what is important is worshipping him in
spirit and amen so the the physical
place is not important anymore what is
important now is that we worship him in
spirit and in truth you must have both
um
so we we're we're not putting emphasis
on and christ did not put emphasis on a
building anymore
the emphasis now is on having christ in
your heart and you being the temple of
the lord so it's a very good question i
really appreciate your your answer
daniel uh well done yeah thank you well
done so
uh in the last minutes that we have
you know
again i go back to
to what you said pastor ca because i
think this is
this is uh
a basic teaching that we should get from
the temple is that
when you read hebrews chapter 11 you
notice that even
the heroes of faith in the bible they
had their eyes fixed not on an
earthly city on an earthly temple yes
but they all looked to a city whose
builder and maker is god to the near
jerusalem so there is a real temple in
heaven hebrews tells us in hebrews
chapter 8 verses 1 through 5 that jesus
is
in
the heavenly century yes that was made
by god himself that was erected by god
himself and he is there ministering for
us
so we should fix our eyes
on that temple and get hope and strength
from jesus christ amen who is
interceding on our behalf amen in that
temple all of our energies
all of our hopes ought to rest in in
heaven
whether a third temple is going to be
built and i don't see that as a biblical
truism we said that
is not really important the thing that
is important is that when christ comes
you are ready to to meet him and you've
lived such a life that prepares you to
hear from his lips the well done thou
good and faithful servant well our time
has fast slipped into eternity allow me
in closing to wish you both grace and
peace through our lord and savior jesus
christ we'll see you again soon bye bye
and god bless
[Music]
you